[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم حلقتنا النهارده
بنحاول ناخد حضراتكم فيها
لجوله نعرف فيها ما يجري داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي هذه الايام عن قرب وبصراحه هل
الحرب وحدت هذا المجتمع الاسرائيلي لي ام
قسمته واظهرت اسوا ما فيه للاجابه على او
لعرض هذه الصوره انا بستيف اليوم صديقي
الدكتور احمد فؤاد انور استاذ العبري
الحديث والخبير والمتخصص في الشان
الاسرائيلي مساء الخير معال الدكتور اهلا
وسهلا استاذ سيد صديقي والباحث المخدم
ربنا يخليك معان الدكتور سؤال مختصر قبل
ما ادخل في التفاصيل حرب او ضربه 7 اكتوبر
وحدت المجتمع الاسرائيلي ام
قسمته يعني بعد تحيه لحضراتكم والمشاهدين
في البدايه كان الشعار فعلا معا سننتصر
وان لا صوت يعلو على صوت المعركه مع
استمرار المعارك نحو شهر مع الخسائر
المستمره مع استمرار رشقات بدا التشقق
والتصدع الذي كانت بوادره موجوده في العشر
شهور السابقه على يوم سبعه تتجذر اكثر
وتبدو جليه اكثر هناك نزاع سياسي بدا يعني
يطفو اكثر
واكثر تمثل في احياء انصار اصلوا كانوا
دخلوا للقبور كانوا هامش الهامش الان
صوتهم بدا يرتفع ويقولوا احنا كنا ماشيين
صح ما الذي حدث من 28 سنه يوم 4 نوفمبر 95
تم اغتيال رابين وتم اجهاض هذا المسار
فالمجموع بتاعه اسلو السيد بتقول ايه في
يوم واحد ا قتل خمس اضعاف سنوات اسلو
انتوا بتقولوا اسلو وقعنا السلام وكان في
خساير ده احنا في يوم واحد تعرضنا لخسائر
بالخمس اضعاف فهذا اليمين القوي الذي يجب
ان يعترف بالفشل اثناء المعركه لاول مره
يتحدثون ان الحساب الان كان في البدايه
صوت العائلات المحتجزين الاسرى خافت ويتم
تخوينهم انتم خونه تيقون الجيش الاسرائيلي
عن اداء مهمته الان عملوا اعتصام عملوا
مقابلات مع رئيس الوزراء قبلوا رئيس
الدوله ابتدى ناس من العسكريين ينضموا لهم
ويدو كانت في البدايه يتم نزع صورهم نزع
مفقودين والاسرى والمحتجزين فهذا هو
التقصير الذي يعادل تقصير 73 والحديث عن
اجرنا اثنين محاكمه جديده للذي قصر على
المستوى المستوى السياسي والمستوى العسكري
لان ما حدث كان لطمه كبرى اللطمه اتت
واسرائيل غير جاهزه اسرائيل كانت تتحدث هل
ستندلع حرب اهليه هل شكل الدوله هيتغير
فاتت هذه الضربه وعلى المستوى العسكري
وعلى المستوى الداخلي لا يوجد تناغم او
توافق النهارده معريف بتتكلم ان هذا
السلوجان هذا الشعار معا سننتصر غير قابل
للتطبيق و فور وقف المعارك سيكون هناك
صوره جديده لاسرائيل في اطار الانقسام
الذي تجذر اكثر استاذن حضرتك معالي
الدكتور اوضح بس لبعض اصدقائنا اللي ممكن
يكونوا مش متابعين الشان الاسرائيلي
الدكتور احمد اشار الى امرين مهمين ان قبل
7 اكتوبر كان اوريدي المجتمع الاسرائيلي
بيعيش حاله انقسام منذ ان جاء نتنياهو
وحكومته الى السلطه في اخر
2022 سبب الخلاف احنا عرضناه قبل كده في
حلقه سوف اضع لكم رابطها لكن باختصار وصحح
ني معالي الدكتور انه نتنياهو جاء مع
مجموعه
من قولات المتطرفين وكان احد اهدافهم طبعا
انه هو نتنياهو نفسه متورد في قضايا
قانونيه وبعض وزراءه متورد في مشاكل
قانونيه يرغبون في تغيير القوانين اللي هي
بدنهم وبالتالي الرقابه الرقيب عليهم هو
المحكمه العليا بيتم تقليص صلاحيات
ويخلصوا صلاحيات المحكمه العليا اللي هي
بتقوم بدور المحكمه الدستوريه في الدول
الاخرى لكن اسرائيل ليس فيها دستور وعليه
المجتمع انقسم ما بين مجموعه بتايد
نتنياهو ومجموعه مؤثره ومهمه تعارضه وكنا
بنتكلم هل اسرائيل داخله على حرب اهليه
ولا لا اذا كان هناك صراع داخل المجتمع
الاسرائيلي هذا واحد الدكتور احمد اشار
الى امر اخر انه كان اوريدي في فريقين في
اسرائيل فريق اسلو اللي هم اقرب الى
اليسار اللي هم راغبين في التفاوض مع
الفلسطينيين ومستعدين الى مناقشه فكره حل
الدولتين لكن هذا التيار اجهد منذ اغتيال
اسحاق رابين من حوالي 28 سنه في سنه
95 من سنه 95 تمام مظبوط فالتيار ده قيل
لهم ان انتم تيار يعني هامشي
و لا تحقق الامن ولا تحقق الام الامن
وبالتالي بدا التيار ييني اللي احد اهم
رموزه في السنوات الاخيره نتنياهو يصعد
باعتباره ان هو قادر ان يحقق الامن
لاسرائيل وكان بيقولوا لهم لو احنا سمعنا
كلام بتوع اسلب اليسار ف دائما في خسائر
ممن يصفونهم بالارهاب الفلسطيني الان انت
بتقول انه مع 7 اكتوبر قالوا لهم طب ما
انتم برض فشلتم والخسائر يوم 7 اكتوبر في
يوم واحد اضعاف او خمس اضعاف الخسائر
التحقق في 28 سنه طب ندخل على التفاصيل مع
الدكتور هل يعني اذا قلنا هنا واضح ان
احنا هنا عندنا خلاف سياسي هل ممكن توجز
لنا الخلاف السياسي يعني في بايجاز يعني
للمشاهد وللتوضيح اليسار لا يطبق شعارات
ليس ينطلق من مواقف اخلاقيه هو يقول امن
اسرائيل يتحقق بان احنا ندي الفلسطيني 22%
وان نفوز اسرائيل علاقات اسرائيل تمتد من
الخليج للمحيط الاطلنطي بمعنى ان الاندماج
في المنطقه والاستفاده وكانت البوادر
ابتدت فعلا العلاقات كانت بدات تندمج في
المنطقه بشكل ما فالجانب بتاع اسلو بيقول
ايه بيقول الجانب الفلسطيني تنازل عن دوله
من البحر للنهر الجانب الفلسطيني اعترف
بدوله اسرائيل فهو قدم الثمن مقدما ولم
يتلقى البضاعه حتى الان فانتم ماشيين
تستفزوا هذا الشعب تضغطوا عليه وهذا لن
يجدي احنا جربنا ده في لبنان واحتل هنا
ووصلنا لبيروت وبالتالي اضطرينا نسحب
ومقاومه طلعت بشكل اكبر متمثله في حزب
الله اخرجنا ياسر عرفات خرجت لنا مقاومه
اكبر فهذه الحلول لم تجدي اللي هي مزيد من
القوه وبيقول انتم دلوقتي مستعدين لالاف
القتلى في غزه هذا هو الحل ان احنا نسيطر
على غزه طب ما في احنا ابنائنا واحفادنا
وابناء اح فدنا سيموتون في هذا المستنقع
فال المنطلق بتاعهم امن اسرائيل يتحقق من
هذا المسار ده صحيح فابتدع صوتهم تاني
وكان نتنياهو حضرتك اشارت تحالف قبل كده
مع واحد زي اجدور ليبرمان ده يمين برده
متطرف بس الحاليين دول خارجين على القانون
الاسرائيلي يعني مش بس متطرفين متطرفين
بالغ التطرف ومجرمين يعني وزير الامن
القومي ده لم يدخل الجيش يوم لم يخدم في
جيش الاحتلال بن جفير وزير الامن القومي
لم يخدم ليوم واحد لخطورته على الامن
الامن الاسرائيلي كان في حضرتك في الشبك
في حاجه اسمها الارهاب اليهودي كانوا ده
سبون تعالى وزير الماليه اظن وسوتش اخوه
في السياسه وفي التوام الروحي تمام وفي
واحد اسمه سكوت عد الكنيس هو خطير على
الامن لانه هو تصرفاته يعني بمعنى ايه شطط
لدرجه ان هو بيعمل سبق مع ايجال عمير مين
اللي يقتل رئيس الوزراء انا ولا واحد تاني
مين ايجال عمير قاتل قاتل رابين اسمه ايج
ال عمير مين اللي كان بينافس ايج العمير
على قتل رئيس الوزراء وزير الامن القوم
الحالي فيير كان كان يتمنى انه يغتال ده
هو عمل حاجه اخطر قدام الكاميرات قال انا
جبت اهو اللوجو بتاع سياره رئيس الوزراء
ربي وكما وصلنا للسياره سنصل اليه وطبعا
اذكركم اسحا حق ربين كان محاوله اغتياله
او الهدف من اغتياله لانه كان حريصا على
انه يعقد سلاما مع الفلسطينيين وال هو كان
يعني يسعى لحل الدولتين بشكل عملي هو لم
يكن يقتل الوقت كان صادق في ابرام السلام
مع الفلسطينيين وعمل حاجه غالبا هي دي
اللي قتلته اسمها وديعه رابين تعهد
بالانسحاب من الجولان اه في مقابل ترتيبات
امنيه فهنا بقى صوروه ان هو نازي اليمين
الاسرائيلي وصوروه ان هو خاين ف خين يختل
وطلع فتوى دينيه باغتياله وتم اغتياله
فانا قصدي هي دي المجموعه اللي احنا
بنتعامل معاها يعني اكدور ليبرمان وهو
ارعن واهوج ومتطرف ونتنياهو دول بالنسبه
لهم يعني ناس مرنه وناس مفرطين فهو دول
اللي قادوا هذه
الولايه لولايه نتانياهو هذه هم دول اللي
راحوا حوره وقالوا نمح و بلده حواره في
الضفه الضفه ما فيهاش حماس فبالتالي هذه
السياسات هي التي ادت ل 7 اكتوبر يعني
حضرتك بتقول ان المجموعه اللي بتحكم
اسرائيل الان ليس هو اليمين ولا حتى
اليمين المتشدد الذي نعرفه اللي كان
بيمثله ليبرمان او نتنياهو حتى ولكنه يمين
بالغ التطرف الديني والتطرف على كل
المستويات وبعضهم زي ما انت بتقول ملاحق
قانونيا وقضائيا طبعا بنج فير بلا خبره
سياسيه وبلا خبره امنيه ووزير امن قومي
خارج مجلس الوزراء الامني الم غ يعني لو
هو عنده خبره لو هيضيف حاجه انما هو جاي
يعبر عن قطعان المستوطنين جاي ينكل
بالفلسطينيين اذا احنا عندنا الخلاف الان
الظاهر على المستوى السياسي باختصار شديد
هو عوده اليسار او عوده المطالبين بحل
الدولتين داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي وحضرتك
قلت نقطه مهمه ان المطالبين بدوله
للاسرائيليين اللي هم عاده في اليسار مش
بيعملوا ده حبا في الفلسطينيين ولكن حبا
في امن اسرائيل صحيح اليمين عاوز يحقق امن
اسرائيل بانه يمحو فلسطين والفلسطينيين
واليسار بيقول هذا لم يجدي ولن يجدي ما
يجدي هو اعطاء الفلسطينيين قدر قليل لان
هم الفلسطينين اوريدي تنازلوا عن مساحه
كبيره و لم يتبقى لهم ال 22 واظن لو
تفاوضوا هيبقى على 11% ولا حاجه من اراضي
فلسطين التاريخيه معاك طبعا لان ال 22 دي
اغلبها الضفه يعني غزه دي تمثل 1% وكسور
الضفه ب تفتتت بقت كانتونات عشان
المستوطنات فبالتالي المتاح دلوقتي انقاذ
ال 1% وعدم تفجير حرب اقليميه طب ده على
المستوى السياسي معال الدكتور هل في
خلافات على المستوى العسكري يعني في تناول
التعامل مع الحرب في غزه طبعا طبعا في
جنرال اسمه اسحاق بريك ياذ السيد من 2018
اسحاق بريك اه ده جنرال على ذمه الاحتياط
دلوقتي خارج الخدمه متقاعد بيقول من 2018
الجيش الاسرائيلي غير جاهز الجيش
الاسرائيلي تدريبه خاطئ الجيش الاسرائيلي
قياداته بيتم اختيارها بشكل خاطئ والناس
تقول له انت يعني ايه اللي انت بتقوله ده
على المحك لقوا ان كلامه صحيح فرئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو استدعاه بعد سبعه انت كنت
بتقول ايه انت قصدك ايه يعني ايه الحل فهو
دلوقتي بيتم استعال فيكتور ليبرمان تم عرض
وزاره الدفاع عليه لان يوف جالنت اثبت
فشله الوزير الدفاع الحال فقاله تعالى ا
فيكتور لمان امسك وزير الدفاع قهم هاتوا
اسحاق بريك الراجل ده من 2018 وطلع صح هو
اصلا في ارتباك فتم الاستقرار على استدعاء
اثنين من
الجنرالات لحكومه طوارئ حكومه الطوارئ
يستدعي وزير دفاع سابق هو بيني جانتس
ورئيس اركان سابق هو ايزن كوت كو وزيرين
في حكومه الطوارئ تنتهي ولايتهم فور
انتهاء المعارك ف قيول اتم ويرفضون العمل
كمستشارين اه وزير الدفاع الحالي لم يستقل
ولم يقال وبالتالي وزير رئيس الاركان نفس
الكلام فالامور دلوقتي فيها تضارب في
الاختصاصات انا عندي وزير دفاع وعندي رئيس
اركان وفي نفس الوقت استعنت
بجنرال علشان ياتوا برتبه وزيرين في حكومه
طوارئ هم خلفيتهم عسكريه اكيد ده هيبقى
عنده راي وده عنده راي ففي ممكن يكون في
خلافات داخل المع متشابه جدا لان ان هم
عينهم جميعا على المحكمه انا دلوقتي بقول
وعيني ان انا لما المحكمه تسالني اقول
والله انا قلت وفلان هو اللي عطاني لا
يقول لك لا لا ده اللي قلته فلان هو اللي
عطاني انت تقصد حضرتك للي مش متابعنا ان
جميع المسؤولين الان اثناء الهجوم يوم
سبعه سوف يحاكمون ويتم التحقيق معهم طبعا
فكل دلوقتي عاوز يتصرف علشان يحاول يقول
ان انا حاولت اعمل الصح لكن ده مش مشكله
انء الله يقص العقوبه يحاول يقلص العقوبه
يحاول يتجاوز يقل الخسائر طب على المستوى
العسكري الخلاف الاساسي ايه يعني ندخل
الحرب ولا ما ندخل ولا يعني يعني ايه ابرز
الخلافات ما بين العسكريين اللي هي
بتنشرها الصحف الاسرائيليه ومراكز الابحاث
او التسريبات ايه يعني هو دلوقتي بره
المجموعه دي في اثنين من الجنرالات
معترضين منضم العائلات الاسرى ودي واقعه
الاسر
والمحتجزين دي واقعه نادره ان اثناء
المعارك يكون جنرالات معترضين وينضمون الى
من يطالبون بوقف حالا وصفقه تبادل حالا لل
اسر والمحتجزين اقول لحضرتك مين وبعد كده
في موشيه بوجي علون ده وزير دفاع سابق
سابق اه وفي دان حالوتس اه اشتباكات بقى
انتوا ازاي تعترضوا معترضين ان الخط اللي
احنا ماشيين عليه ده غلط ان الحل ان
القياده دي اثبت فشل ثبت فشلها لازم تقر
انها اخطات وانها غير جديره انها غير
امينه المشكله السيد ان بيقولوا احنا ما
مصدقكش احنا نصدق حزب الله نصدق مصر نصدق
اي حد غير نتنياهو انت حرك بتقول دلوقتي
انه الانقسام بغض النظر عن التفاصيل ان في
اثنين جنرالات منهم واحد كان وزير دفاع
سابق اه منهم واحد وزير دفاع سابق والثاني
جنرال كبير رئيس اركان كان رئيس اركان
يعني اهم ضابط في الجيش الاسرائيلي كلاهما
انضم الى المتظاهرين او اللي هم اهالي
المحتجزين
والاسرى دول مش بيتكلموا بقى في التفاصيل
دول بيقولوا لازم الحكومه دي تذهب لان انا
لا نثق فيها بالضبط ثم نبدا النقاش ماذا
نفعل هو بيقول ان نتانياهو خطر على
اسرائيل خطر على اسرائيل ف الخطر على
الاسرائيل يزال الان انت مش قادر تشيل
وزير التراث اللي بيقول نلقي قنبله زهريه
على غازه انا هسال حضرتك عن وزير التراث
اذا ده الخلاف الاساسي انه في جنرالات
شايفين انه قبل ما نتكلم على مسار العمليه
الاول نتكلم على مسار القياده نزيل
القياده الحاليه صحيح صحيح انما احنا هن
قاتل هناك بري هنقل سنوات هنستمر
هنتفاكس الخطر الرئيسي هو نتنياهو فاشل
وكداب طيب على ذكر نتنياهو وعلى ذكر وزير
التراث انا ملاحظ وحضرتك صلحني انه مع
الارتباك الكبير ظهرت ا نبره دينيه
واستدعاء للدين باكثر مما ينبغي يعني انا
كنت اعرف انه الاهم المؤثرين في المجتمع
الاسرائيلي هو العلماني الاسرائيلي اللي
بيحكم العقل والحسابات وكذا لكن واضح ان
حتى واحد زي نتنياهو وهو علماني بامتياز
عمال يستخدم نبوءات انجيليه وتورا تيه
وعندنا تيار كبير من بقوا في الحكومه وفي
الكنيست من اصحاب التيار الديني ممكن
تديني فكره عن التيار الديني كده دلوقتي
وضعه ايه وانقسامات بينهم ايه يعني هو
طبعا في جزء
ا بيسموه صهيونيه دينيه اه ده بيحاول
يتوسط بين الحريديم الرافضين للدوله ولصه
نيه ويتوسط بين التيار العلماني اللي هما
التلتين المجتمع اه اللي اسسوا الدوله
علمانيين تمام بمعنى ان مالهمش علاقه و
حتى لو تسالهم يقول لهم ما فيش طرب اليهود
اه فمن اولها ديفيد بن جورين ومن جاء بعده
من اول هيرتس اه من اول اه تيدر هيرتس ما
ختن ابنه فدي بالنسبه لهم حتى لو جثه لازم
تختين اه بيقول الحخامات مكانهم في
المعابد مالهمش علاقه ده تيدور هيرتز اه
ده نبي الصهيونيه ده اللي اسس ده صح مؤسس
الصهيونيه فده ما ختن ابنه ده بالنسبه
لليهود اه ده مش يهودي يعني اه طبعا مالوش
علاقه وهم دلوقتي بيقولوا كده بيقول دي
دوله كفر ليه لان انت بتعترض على مشيئه
السماء احنا كده بنتكلم على الحارم
الحريديم رافضين للسه هنايه بدرجات اه
كلهم يقول لك انتم دوله تقوم على الزندقه
اه انتم لا تثقون في السماء تعترضون على
مشي تستعجلوا الخلاص ما فيش حاجه اسمها
كده في حاجه اسمها علامات تيجي بعدها يظهر
المسيح اليهودي المخلص بيسس مملكه اسرائيل
بما ان ده ما ظهرش ما يصحش ان انتم تبقوا
دول يصحش نفضل في
الشتات اه اللي عايز يحج ويجي يصلي ويمشي
وممنوع ان انت تشتغل اصلا يعني تقعد تصلي
تتلقى
الصدقات طيب عشان دي قصه طويله استاذنك
مره استضيفك ونتكلم فيها بالتفصيل بس الان
احنا عندنا طيارين
اساسيين دينيين واذا قلنا اسرائيل عندنا
ثلاث طيارات عندنا العلمانيين اللي احنا
نعرفهم سياسيين عاديين زيهم زي غيرهم
وعندنا طيارين دينيين الصهيونيه الدينيه
اللي منها بن غفير وسش اللي هو وزير الامن
الداخلي ووزير الماليه تمام وعندنا الحردي
اللي هم الاصوليين اللي هم رافضين للنيه
اللي هم رافضين للدوله اصلا اص وبيقولوا
ان الدوله ديت دوله كافره لانها قامت ضد
مشيئه الله ومشيئه الله من وجهه نظرهم
تتحقق ان اسرائيل تقوم حين يات المسيح هم
مش مقتنعين ان المسيح جاء طيب الخلاف الان
بينهم ايه فيما يتعلق بالحرب الحرب طلع في
جريده يت بنمان اجهاض لفكره ايه الفكره ان
الجيش الاحتلال دلوقتي عنده مازق في ناس
مش عايزه تيجي في ناس مش استدعى اه من
الاول في ناس متردده فلما بقى قامت حرب مش
عايز يجي وخصوصا الجنسيات المزدوجه خصوصا
لو هو في الخارج لو قدر ان هو يعني يتغيب
شهر شهرين المهم ان هو دلوقتي في حاجه
لاستدعاء الاحتياطي خاصه اللي يعرفوا
يضربوا نار في جزء كبير من جيش الاحتلال
مش مؤهل لاطلاق النار من الاساس اه انا
راجل مراقبه انا مش ما بضرب نار ماعرفش
اضرب نار فدي جزئيه طبعا مثيره للسخريه ان
تاهيل يعني محط علامات استفهام فهو عايز
يستعد الاحتياطي بالكامل عايز الحريديم
ينضموا اللي
هم رافضين للدوله بدرجات وبالتالي رافضين
للتجنيد فهو المفترض لو هو شاف جندي من
جيش الاسرائيلي بيعدي جوه الحي بتاعه
يضربه اه وده بيحصل بيضرب ويعتدي عليه
فبيقول
له يعني تعالى انضم لي تخيل الصدمه الكبرى
يعني ففي 120 واحد استجابوا 120 واحد من
الحرادي م استجابوا استجابوا قالوا احنا
هنيجي بشروطنا وهو دايما الجيش الاسرائيلي
يقول له تعال بشروطك انت مش عايز تختلط
بالبنات انا المجندات هيبقوا على بعد 7
كيلو من في معسكر تاني انت عايز تاكل اكل
حلال انا هضبط لك الاكل الحلال وفق
الشرايه اليهوديه انت عايز يوم السبت كذا
انا معاك يوم السبت في كذا فهو دلوقتي
بيقول له ايه تعالى وغلف لنا الوجبات غلف
اي اي دور سوق عربيه الاسعاف اشتغل سواء
ففي 120 استجابوا في جزء منه اغراء مادي ف
حخام بتاعهم طلع في يت الدمان اللي هي
جريده ناطقه باسم التيار الليتواني
الحريديم في تيار اسمه الليتواني وده تيار
رئيسي اه مش مش مشمشي زي ناتوري كارتا
مشهور مجموعه اسمها ناتوري كارتا دول اقصى
المجموعه الرافضه الاسرائيل ي يعلقوا علم
اسود يوم قيام دوله اسرائيل الذكر يرف
التعامل بالشكل لهم توقيت مختلف بيتعاملوا
يطلبوا جواز سفر بدون جنسيه من الامم
المتحده وقابلوا اسماعيل هنيه وقابلوا
قاده ايران دول اللي دايما بييجوا عندنا
الدول العربيه وانت جبت منهم وفد مصر مره
واظن انت قابلتهم مرتين في جامعه الازهر
اول مره جامعه الازهر تحرت حطتهم في صفوف
الخلفيه ثاني مره فهمت قيمتهم ان جايين
بالكوفيه الفلسطينيه واغز وض فنتوري كارتا
واحد من الطيارات للطيار الرئيسي اللي هو
الحريديم اللي هو هم ضد الدوله بدرجات بال
طيب جزء من اللي انت حضرتك بتقول عليه
اللي هو اللي هو التيار التواني اه الحديد
الليتواني ق واحد منهم قالوا ممنوع نساعد
احنا دورنا احنا دورنا نصلي اه احنا دورنا
ندعوا انما ان احنا نتجن او نساعد اصل
الفكره كلمه نساعد دي الجديده بلاش تخدم
تعال سيع فهو الحاخام
الجديد وده اثار ايه بقى اثار المجموعه
بلتين العلمانيين اللي بيدفعوا ضريبه الدم
وبيقول لك انا معطل شغلي واحتمال اتصاب
واحتمال اموت وانت مش عايز تيجي تغلف لي
هي حاجه في منتهى الغرابه انا مش قادر
اتخيلها استاذنك انت صلح لي اولا ان غريبه
بالنسبه لي انا انا بسمعها واعرف منك يعني
انه الدوله تيجي تقول للناس من فضلك تعالى
اع تعال للخدمه خاصه لو كان بلد يم على
الاستدعاء صح ف ولما يتفاوض معاه يقوله
طيب تعال الجيش وبشروط ده واحد حاجه مثيره
ا ست شهور مش لازم سنتين ونص الغريبه طبعا
لمن لا يعلم ان يكون في عدد ضخم من التيار
الحريديم اللي هم رافضين للدوله دول عدد
كبير يكون رافض الخدمه العسكريه طبعا وانت
دلوقتي بتقول ان المشكله ثارت الان لانه
هم عاوزين استدعاء 300 350 ال فعاوز اي حد
صح في جزء عاوز هربان منهم ابن نتنياهو
نفسه نفسه مش كده برض طبعا والناس بتلحق
المح
والمفروض يجي يخدم معان طيب دلوقتي انت
بتقول حتى اللي وافقوا طلع اللي وافقوا
للحرم حرام اه طلعت فاتو ان حرام ان انت
تروح الجيش فالجانب العلماني يقول انتم
كائنات طفيليه طبعا ققل واجب يشتمهم طبعا
يعني انا بموت وانت مش عايز تيجي تساعد
فبالتالي في شقاق وانقسام برز اكتر بسبب
الصدام مع او الحرب ضد القصاء للمقاومه طب
معال الدكتور في مقابل التيار الديني اللي
هو واخد موقف من الدوله في تيار ديني ثاني
اظن اللي هو الصهيونيه الدينيه اللي
بينتمي اليها وزير الامن القومي اللي هو
بن غفير وهو طيب الذكر اسمه ريتش في في
الطيار ده في كهنه او
متدينين مش بس راغبين في الانضمام للجيش
ولكن راغبين في اصدار فتاوى ل امعان القتل
في الاغي يعني والفلسطينيين ممكن تدينا
فكره ما حدث في الايام الماضيه من هذا
التيار هو طبعا في سند بيستن ليه التيار
الصونيه الدينيه هو كتاب اسمه شريعه الملك
سبع حخ مات واحد فيهم تراجع بعد كده قال
لا والله انا بسحب تاييدي للكتاب بيقول
اقتلوا حتى الاطفال الردع لانه في يوم مين
من مين من الاغيار اغيار غير اليهود غير
اليهود جويم بيسموهم جوييم ليه لانه في
يوم من الايام هي مثل عليك خطا في يوم من
الايام فم انت من دلوقتي اقتله اقتله في
حالات ثانيه اقل تطرفا يقول لك لو غير
اليهودي بيغرق ما تنقذه طب ليه يا سيدي
قال لك في وصايا اللي اسمها وصايا نوح
السبع بعد الطوفان يجب على غير اليهودي
يلتزم بها منها مثلا عدم التعري وكذا وكذا
وكذا فانت بالنسبه له كافر وغير ملتزم
بهذه الوصايا فيجب قتل او يعرف منين ان
انا غير ملتزم بهذه الوص انت تعريت مثلا
هو بيقدر ان ده بيقدر ان انت راجل
فبي قرر ان يقتلك او لو معتدل يسيبك تموت
وكتاب شريعه الملك ديت كتاب شائع ومثر
طبعا مؤثر مدارس دينيه تعتمد وطبعا
بالنسبه لهم ارض اسرائيل الكبرى او
الكامله دي مقدسه فلا يجب التفريط فيها
اللي يفرض فيها يبقى خاين فعلى هذا منوال
طلع لنا وزير التراث اليهودي ا عمي حاي
يقول طبعا التراث اليهودي بيقول عكس اللي
هو بيقوله ا فبيقول يا جماعه نلقي قنبله
ذريه على غزه من ضمن الخيارات يعني ليه لا
ف قالوا له التراث اليهودي بيقول في قره
جوه ويجب علينا ان احنا ننقذهم ده التراث
اليهودي اللي انت وزير ليه ثاني حاجه انت
هتطلع لنا ديول فبيقول لهم ديول ايه
بيقولوا له انت دلوقتي عمق 6 كيلو لو ما
متناش بالغبار النووي حتى لو محدوده قنبله
محدوده
تكتيكيه الغبار هيجينا بعد 6 كيلو فلو ما
متناش هيطلع لنا ديول واورام سرطانيه بحجم
دماغك البايظه ا دماغك البايظه ده ناس
كتبوا كده كسب وكاتب النص على اساس ان
القنبله النوويه وهو الاراضي كلها لازقه
ببعضها يعني طبعا طبعا طبعا فهو بيقول له
انت تفكيرك غلط وهو تفكيره كده تفكيره ان
هو يبيد الجميع ان دول اغيار ان دول الخطر
ان دول بجزء من ارض اسرائيل الكامله لازم
المشكله ان هم بيخشوا على الاردن يقول لك
الاردن الضفه الشرقيه جزء من اراضينا بعد
ما كانت اوهام ايام العصابات الصونيه وزير
الماليه بيتبنى هذا الشعار ويتحدث تحت
مظلته ومازال متمسك بالكلام ده هو كان
قاله من فتره طويله اه بيترا جع طبعا بس
اللي في القلب في القلب يعني هو بيسموها
ذله لسان لا ده ليها مرجعيه ان هو بيعتبر
الاردن يجب ان تكون جزءا من اسرائيل اغلب
الاردن اغلب الاردن في اي كلام داخل النخب
الاسرائيليه عن وقف الحرب عن وقف الهجوم
على غزه ولا في اجماع ان كله لازم يعني
نستمر الهجوم لا الصف انشق بان في اسره
جوه لازم نطلعهم بعد كده نتكلم اه في شق
شك مدني ده ليه اولويه يطلع الاول او
نطلعهم كلهم وبعد كده نتكلم نشوف هنحلها
عسكري ولا سياسي انما ده الضرب العشوائي
باطنان من من المتفجرات اه
يلحق يلحق الادب بالمحتجزين وبالاس
المحتجزين هم المدنيين والاسرى اللي هم
العسكريين هل التيار ده قوي ولا مازال
مغلوب على امره كل ما ساعه تمر والرشيقات
تستمر من المقاومه التيار ده ينمو ويتزايد
ويجتذب مزيد من المؤيدين من المناصرين حتى
رغم التضييق الاعلامي اللي بيقول احنا
شرطه الاحتلال ونحذر اي خبر سواء على
السوشيال ميديا او على المواقع يخفض من
الروح المعنويه للجنود اثناء الحار يعرض
للحبس هو دلوقتي اسرائيل اللي هي البلد
اللي هي بلد الحريات يعني الديق بتلاح
اليهود حتى اللي هم بيحاولوا يتكلموا او
يعبروا عن ارائهم طبعا طبعا بوستات بيتم
فورا اقتيادهم سواء اعدو كنيست سواء فنان
سواء هو من فلسطين ال 48 على سبيل الردع
انت ازاي تقول كده انت بتحاول تقلل من
خسينا في 7 اكتوبر تعال تقلل من خسايرها
ولا تزود من خسايرها اه بيقول ان ده فيلم
في واحده في واحده بتقول انا عضو كنيست
وشايفه يعني ان الارقام والاحداث دي مش
منطقيه اه اه هو ازاي تمت كده انا حاسه ان
في مبالغه في الارقام فزي الشقاع بقى اللي
هي الكارثه النازيه او الاحداث النازيه
ممنوع ان انت ده تابو ف 7 اكتوبر تحول
لتابو هي الروايه دي ما حدش يتكلم فيها
دول دخلوا على مدنيين رغم ان المدنيين دول
ليها قوه تحرسهم رغم ان هم دخلوا قياده
الفرقه اللي هي اسمها فرقه غزه واحتجزوا
جنرالات وليس مجرد عساكر التركيز يجب ان
يكون ان مدنيين تم التعرض لهم واختطافهم
هل من ضمن الشرطه ديت او السلطات
الاسرائيليه ان هي بتحاول وهي المفروض ان
هي دوله فيها مؤسسات بتحاول تتلاعب بارقام
القتلى والخسائر اللي بتقع على ايدي
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اه طبعا في دلوقتي
حديث عن ان الارقام بيتم ازاحتها لحوادث
الطرق على سبيل الخسائر ليست كبيره في
القتال انما في واحد كان رايح يتفسح في
اجازه في ايلات فالعربيه ا اتقلبت فهو
بالتالي من بالصدفه كان ضابط في خمسه هناك
في الشمال بالصدفه كانوا ضباط فهو المشكله
كمان الخسائر في قوات النخبه عاليه
التدريب القوات المدرعات قوات المشاه عليه
التدريب وان في تخطيط سيء ان في مروحيه
تتحرك فض يب عليها 33 بقوا 55 ف الصاروخ ا
اصابها واسقطها شكرا جزيلا معالي الدكتور
شكرا لحضراتكم ونلقاكم في حلقات اخرى باذن
الله